okay so i have this idea that i don't
really think avengers 5 if we can call
it that i don't really think avengers 5
is going to be secret wars i think it's
going to be called secret wars and i
think it's going to borrow elements from
secret wars but i think it's going to be
more in line with avengers forever so
let's do a little bit of explanation
here so you know what i'm talking about
then we'll get into how it is that i
think this is going to unfold combining
these two things together
so let's talk about secret wars 2015
because that seems to be the on running
theory of which version of secret wars
they're likely going to use and a lot of
that was really speculation going into
doctor strange 2 coming out of doctor
strange 2 and the revelation of the
existence of incursions it's basically
secret wars 2015 that it looks like
they're drawing on here so the way this
whole thing works going into seeker wars
is you had jonathan hickman's avengers
new event his best story ever told but
the reason why it's called that is
because you had two different stories
going at the same time new avengers
dealt with the illuminati directly
focusing on the incursions avengers was
just a series of events that built up or
helped to build up to a story arc called
time runs out so the way it works is
that where avengers and new avengers
were telling separate stories with time
runs out you get an eight month time
skip and basically during time runs out
it's everybody learning about the
incursions the collapse of the
multiverse all that kind of stuff and
essentially a coming together of the
superhero community and so one of the
things that you had that went on there
was a guy named robert decosta who was
the super rich member of the x-men who
basically was a billionaire and he
bankrolled something called the
multiversal avengers this was a
ridiculously op avengers team you had
like thor and hyperion who just between
the two of them are more than enough to
handle thanos to give you perspective
and then you had star brand who is
basically a guy that had as much power
as he needed to defeat whatever villain
he was facing off against but that was
the cap so if you were to fight galactus
he would have enough power to fight
galactus and no more than that he was
designed to just be a planetary
planetary protector i know it's a
mcguffin but it's still a cool concept
like the last white event that story was
amazing oh my god i loved it but still
you had this really really powerful team
and there were other people who were on
it as well um but you had this really
powerful team their job was to go into
the multiverse and to find the ivory
kings right the white lords of wild
space who turned out to be the beyonders
and of course they all died
the last stand of thorn hyperion is one
of the greatest moments in the history
of comics dude let me tell you something
man you want to read a story where two
ridiculously amazing characters go out
guns blazing i mean it was the battle of
the alamo is what this was literally
thor's got one arm he can't lift his
hammer well it's a hammer from a
different universe but he can't lift it
um hyperion is basically blind his eyes
were gouged out of his head um so
literally these guys it's the last stand
and like the beyonders come pouring out
of the beyond verse and it's just thor
and hyperion and these guys are just
just god's blazing right and it's like
this amazing this amazing description
right it's like in the bleak cold
nothingness of space to god stood
against many there was a crack of
thunder
something else and then silence and it
was just like damn yeah they it was it
was a it was just this ridiculously
amazing moment it was just crafted so
perfectly uh but of course again they
all basically ended up dying but i want
you to keep that idea of the multiversal
avengers in mind because we'll circle
back around to that here in a little
while but then you go into avengers
forever now avengers forever was a story
that was written in the late 1990s and
was in a lot of ways a huge influence
for the loki tv series not exactly right
there were massive differences between
avengers forever and the loki tv series
however the loki tv series i'm sorry the
avengers forever storyline essentially
dealt with like immortus he who remains
essentially in the loki tv show kang the
conqueror the time keepers that kind of
stuff so you can see the huge
similarities that were being drawn on
there but the big significance about
avengers forever is that it was
basically a story that saw the avengers
or members of the avengers so like
captain america uh hank pym hawkeye
people like that basically being yanked
out of different time periods and coming
together and working together as a
singular team in order to defeat like
the time keepers and actually kang
worked alongside them different things
like that now the reason why i say all
of that matters is because if you look
at doctor strange too this had huge
revelations one of the first things this
revealed to us is that a
there are
other universes out there where groups
like the illuminati or any number of
groups out there are seemingly aware of
the multiverse much more so than anybody
in the main marvel cinematic universe
was the only experience steven strange
had as sorcerer supreme with the
multiverse was the experience he got at
the hands of the ancient one in the
first doctor strange movie and then the
spell he cast and spider-man no way home
and like doctor strange too that's it
like quite literally in terms of like
the multiverse where steven strange has
just now opened his front door and is
stepping outside
you know presumably when you look at the
illuminati they've been walking around
outside for a long time
they're well aware of the multiverse
right and and so so you have to assume
that in other realities people know more
about the multiverse than basically the
marvel cinematic universe does right
like we're literally the last ones to
figure it out and so you have to believe
that if that's the case the events of
loki ring true and what you have now is
kang the conqueror at the end of time
instead of he who remains and kang is
basically conquering the multiverse or
at least maybe it already conquered it
and now that the sacred timeline the
sacred multiverse as we can call it has
rejoined the rest of the multiverse now
it all falls under the control of kang
you have to have to believe there are
other universes and groups of people out
there who are aware of it now the
question that would really have to be
asked here is just right off the bat
were the illuminati aware of kane the
conqueror did they know about kane the
conqueror i don't know the answer to
that question it was never never even
hinted at or alluded to in any form or
fashion it's not like we saw iron lad
who's basically kane the conqueror
before he becomes king the conqueror
working as a superhero to try to keep
himself from becoming king the conqueror
it's not like we saw him as far as i'm
aware there were no references to kang
the existence of kang the events of loki
or anything like that so we don't
necessarily know if they knew i would
assume they did maybe they were working
on it behind the scenes but the
immediate threat was what was going on
with doctor strange and like creating
incursions things along those lines the
circumstances didn't present an
opportunity to talk about kane the
conqueror so it would just be injecting
information in there that's not
necessary and for no other reason than
to give us the audience you know an
indication that like the illuminati know
about cain the conqueror so if we assume
they did know we can also assume other
groups around the around the universe
around the multiverse snow which begs
the question
are there any groups out there that are
fighting off against the forces of king
that unless kang is just sitting at the
end of time watching the multiverse
unfold then he's got to be doing
something right whether it's meddling
with a time stream or something like
that are there groups out there working
against him and so ultimately i think
that's what avengers 5 would in effect
be that the illuminati and doctor
strange two basically gave us our first
glimpse into the idea that there are
organized superhero teams that exist out
there in the multiverse that are
composed of some pretty heavy hitters if
we add in the caveat that they are aware
of kang we also have to add in the
caveat some of them are fighting against
king and so what i think would happen
when it came to like the avengers 5
secret wars slash avengers forever type
film is we would basically get a coming
together of a handful of superheroes and
groups some of which may be identical so
one version of iron man right we get
like robert downey jr who returns as
iron man by some weird circumstance i
don't know they pluck him out of time or
something like that but then we finally
get tom cruise's superior iron man from
some other reality we get toby mcguire
we get andrew garfield we get tom
holland right even if nobody knows uh
who peter parker is in the main marvel
cinematic universe right we get him back
or something like that maybe stephen
strange casts a spell we're only he and
everybody else there knows right
whatever the case is we basically get
that return but we get those heroes
plucked out from different realities now
here's the thing about this if they went
in this direction this is not a one
movie gimmick you can't do this in one
film if you did it would baffle the hell
out of people or the movie would have to
be like four hours it's way too much to
cram in so i could see them doing this
as a two-part film or as a phase right
like some kind of a fade like a series
of events but we already know from the
end of doctor strange too with clea
grabbing stephen strange that the idea
of incursions is affecting the dark
dimension right it's infecting other
realities or you know other other places
that require him to be involved those
kind of little post credit scenes those
small little buildups are a great way to
segue that information in so that by the
time you get to avengers 5 whether it's
because of previously existing films
that have added like a broad scope of
all this information or just post credit
scenes and movies that kind of piece it
all together that people go into that
movie knowing exactly what to expect
basically you got the the prologue right
the you got the the ex the exposition in
terms of what's happening by way of
other movies and post credit scenes i
think at this point in the mcu right if
this was in the era like in the first 10
years or even the first five years i'd
say no that's a bit of a stretch but i
think at this point in time post-credit
scenes are so widely acknowledged and
they're they're so often remembered by
people who see those movies that you
kind of you can get away with treating
them as like information that you
essentially need to understand what
comes next because they're so ingrained
in the mcu i mean even now right i mean
you can't tell me with a straight face
when you were watching moon night that
you were just waiting for a mid-credits
or a post-credits scene right it's a
core part of the mcu so i could see them
leaning into that and saying okay like
we need this and even if it's something
that people forget we have the whole
internet at our disposal right it's
non-stop articles when movies when
movies start coming out right remember
this post-credits scene remember that
post-credits scene so i could see them
pulling something off like this but what
it does it is it solidifies the role of
king it solidifies the significance of
king that what this is in terms of it
living up to the namesake of a secret
war is it quite literally is that it's a
war that's being fought that not
everybody is aware of right it quite
literally is a secret war being fought
in the multiverse against kane the
conqueror because most people don't know
it's happening the average person
walking around in their life has no clue
that the multiverse even exists let
alone a guy at the end of it all is the
one ruling and manipulating everything
right like it's it's pretty much a
secret but it also brings in that
avengers forever type idea where you get
different superheroes who are brought in
from other realities that are all
basically aiding in this fight against
king and it would be pretty massive in
scale i mean you're talking about a
pretty huge conflict right i mean let's
take for example the events of infinity
war and avengers in-game right remember
like the battle in wakanda let's take
that battle and extrapolate it out and
let's say that they basically copied
infinity which is where that battle is
based off of let's say they they copy
the infinity storyline by jonathan
hickman where you have a fight in
wakanda and a fight in new york in a
fight in atlantis and a fight in uh in
upstate new york at the uh in west uh
westchester at the xavier institute you
have like five battles all happening at
the same time as part of this greater
war which is thanos essentially invading
the earth now expand that out and you've
got a you've got a conflict happening in
this universe and that universe and an
alternate universe and it's not that
unreasonable literally avengers in game
was a movie where we watched people
groups of people doing different things
in different time periods it's not a
hard concept to keep up with and i
honestly i think most people could
handle it most people could follow it
they would be like yeah i mean i can
keep up with this i think a couple
movies is necessary like a two-part
movie is necessary there in order to
really grasp the significance of it all
otherwise you would rush through too
much and the the
the gravity of the situation would be
lost on the moviegoer because things are
just happening so fast you don't really
have enough time to absorb everything
but i think this is entirely possible
and i think this may most likely be the
direction that they're heading in that
it is kang but it's basically a
combination of secret wars and avengers
forever so let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section i
mean you guys think this is entirely
possible that we're looking at just
alternate reality teams banding together
to face off against cain the conqueror
as a singular team or do you think it'll
be something different let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
thank you all for watching i will catch
you all later
peace